yeah so that we're not just
passive observers of our genetics the
more we understand the more we can come
up with actual treatments
and i think that's an important uh
aspect to realize
when people are thinking about uh strong
effect versus weak effect variants
so some variants have strong effects we
talked about these mendelian disorders
where a single gene has a sufficiently
large effect
pen and trans expressivity and so forth
that basically
you can um trace it in families with
cases and not cases cases not cases and
so forth
but even the you know but
so so these are the genes that everybody
says oh that's the genes we should go
after
because that's a strong effect gene i
like to think about it slightly
differently
these are the genes where genetic
impacts that have a strong effect were
tolerated
because every single time we have a
genetic association with disease
it depends on two things number one the
obvious one
whether the gene has an impact on the
disease number two the more subtle one
is whether there is genetic in variation
standing and circulating and segregating
in the human population
that impacts that gene some genes
are so darn important that if you mess
with them even a tiny little amount
that person is dead so those genes don't
have variation
you're not going to find the genetic
association if you don't have variation
that doesn't mean that the gene has no
role it's simply that the gene
it simply means that the gene tolerates
no mutations so that's actually a strong
signal when there's no variation that's
so fast
exactly genes that have very little
variation
are hugely important you can actually
rank the importance of genes
based on how little variation they have
and those genes that have very little
variation
but no association with disease
that's a very good metric to say oh
that's probably a developmental gene
because we're not good at measuring
those phenotypes so it's genes that you
can tell
evolution has excluded mutations from
but yet we can't see them associated
with anything that we can measure
nowadays
it's probably early embryonic lethal
what are all the words you just said
earlier in brionic what
lethal meaning meaning that
there's a bunch of stuff that um
is required for a stable functional
organism
exactly across the board for our entire
for for entire species i guess if you
look at sperm
it expresses thousands of proteins
does sperm actually need thousands of
proteins no
but it's probably just testing them
so my specific relationship is that
misfolding of
these proteins is an early test for
failure
so that out of the you know millions of
sperm that are
possible you select the subset that are
just not
grossly misfolding thousands of proteins
so it's kind of
an assert uh that this is followed
correctly correct
yeah this uh just uh because if this
little thing about the folding of a
protein isn't correct
that probably means somewhere down the
line there's a bigger issue
that's exactly right so fail fast so
basically if you look at
the mammalian investment in
a new born that investment is enormous
in terms of resources
so mammals have basically evolved
mechanisms
for fail fast where basically in those
early
months of development i mean it's it's
horrendous of course at the personal
level
when you lose a uh you know your future
child
but in some ways
there's so little hope for that child to
develop
and sort of make it through the
remaining months that sort of fail fast
is probably
a good evolutionary principle from an
evolutionary perspective for
mammals and of course humans
have a lot of medical resources that you
can sort of give those children a chance
and you know we have so much more
success in sort of giving folks who have
these strong carrier mutations a chance
but if they're not even making it
through the first three months
we're not going to see them so that's
why when we
when we say what are the most important
genes to focus on the ones that have a
strong effect mutation
or the ones that have a weak effect
mutation well you know the jury might be
out
because the ones that have a strong
effect mutation are basically
you know not mattering as much the ones
that only have weak effect mutations
by understanding through genetics that
they have a weak effect mutation
and understanding that they have a
causal role on the disease we can then
say okay great evolution has only
tolerated a two percent
change in that gene pharmaceutically
i can go in and induce a 70 change in
that gene
and maybe i will poke another hole at
the bathtub
that was not easy
to control in you know many of the other
sort of strong effect genetic variants
so okay so there's this beautiful map
of uh across the population of things
that hot
you're saying strong and weak effects so
stuff with a lot of
mutations and stuff with little
mutations with
no mutations and you have this map and
it's it lays out the puzzle
yeah so so when i say strong effect i
mean at the level of individual
mutations
so so basically genes where
so so you have to think of first the
effect of the gene on the disease
remember how i was sort of
painting that map earlier from genetics
all the way to phenotype
that gene can have a strong effect on
the disease
but the genetic variant might have a
weak effect on
the gene so basically when you ask
what is the effect of that genetic
variant on the disease
it could be that that genetic variant
impacts the gene by a lot
and then the gene impacts the disease by
a little or it could be that the genetic
variance
impacts the gene by a little and then
the gene impacts the disease by a lot
so what we care about is genes that
impact the disease a lot
but genetics gives us the full equation
and what i would argue
is if we couple the genetics
with expression variation
to basically ask what genes change by a
lot
and you know which genes correlate with
disease by a lot
even if the genetic variants change them
by a little
then that those are the best places to
intervene
those are the best places where
pharmaceutically if i
have even a modest effect i will have a
strong effect on the disease
whereas those genetic variants that have
a huge effect on the disease
i might not be able to change that gene
by this much without affecting all kinds
of other things
you